on voit sur la carte en rouge tchernobyl
marina il ya une crainte qui est apparu
ce matin oui tout à fait tchernobyl on
la connaît cette ville la centrale
nucléaire avec cet accident dans les
années 80 et c'est toutes dernières
informations très inquiétantes qui nous
parvient concernant cette centrale
nucléaire elle est occupée par l'armée
russe et on apprend que l'électricité a
été coupée sur le site ce qui empêche le
refroidissement du combustible nucléaire
usagé en l'occurrence l'uranium l'accès
à cette centrale vous voyez qu'elle se
trouve dans une zone contrôlée par
l'armée russe l'accès à cette centrale
pour rétablir l'électricité est
totalement impossible on a eu cette
réaction de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique qui dit avoir perdu
le contact avec les systèmes de contrôle
du matériau radioactif traduction des
substances radioactives pourraient
s'échapper de la centrale nucléaire je
vous en dirai plus tu es qu'on a
davantage d'informations